good evening
[Music]
it's an honor for me to be here tonight
on behalf of a pioneering director
Hussein polsey
Roseanne has had a fascinating life
then again most Legends do
but tonight
I want to focus on her work
for it is through her work that she has
made her Mark speaking truth to power
pulling back the curtain on things that
were hidden from for so many
sharing with a global audience stories
that needed to be told
and I'll try to limit my use of the word
first
in telling her story although given her
career it's almost impossible
her breakthrough film was sugarcane
alley
next year is its 40th anniversary and
its story is just as compelling today as
it was back then
set in her Homeland in the 1930s in an
era where the natives of Martinique
worked in the sugarcane Fields received
Through The Eyes of its protagonist Jose
the incredibly harsh life
his people LED under the French Colonial
rule
to me in addition to being visually
stunning
the film endures because its story
allows us to see both the Heartbreak and
hope of that world
sugarcane Ali won the silver lion at the
1983 Venice film festival and a Caesar
Award for best first work first
the first Caesar won by a woman director
and by a black filmmaker
great directors have a signature film
for Hussein it is a dry white season
this drama made at the height of
apartheid tells the story of a South
African suburbanite who agrees to help
his black Gardener find his jailed son
along the way his investigation opens
his eyes to the horrors committed by the
secret police but more important seeing
that film Open the Eyes of so many to
the horrors of that time in history
the film premiered in 1989 but its
urgency back then makes it just as
relevant in the world of today as it did
back then
a quick Side Story after learning of
Hussein's commitment to her story and to
social change Marlon Brando decided to
return to the screen after a nine-year
absence and even more amazing Brando was
so moved by Hussein's passion that he
agreed to work for union scale
remember this is the same Marlon Brando
who demanded a huge fee for a few
minutes screen time for Superman
if that's not proof of Hussein's talent
and Relentless dedication to her work
nothing is
with these films
and all her other work Hussein has been
an inspiration to me to filmmakers
to contemporary artists to novelists
Across the globe
and
if I were to be bold to say
oh saying
everybody has a different process
they really do
but we all have the same goal
and as a black
woman artists
I feel like I'm always defending my
Womanhood and blackness
I am always going out in the world
searching for that work
that's going to catapult me blow up in
the world and have it mean something to
somebody
you
said I ain't gonna do that
I'm gonna wait
for the work that is worthy of me
you did not defend your Blackness you
did not defend your Womanhood
you used it as Warrior fuel
and then my big question
which is rhetorical
is why are we artists
we want to create things that move
people make them tremble change them
shift them make them feel less alone
is that it
I think a better question is what do we
live for
right
and it's like the old Cherokee birth
blessing that says may I live long
enough
to know why I was born
you're epitomizing Emil Zola quote as
I'll tell you what I came here to do
I an artist
came here to live out loud
I was saying once said that some people
make movies for money or Glory
and will take any subject people offer
them
but I cannot do that
I need to feel the story and make it
mind
and in a groundbreaking career she has
done just that
let's take a look at some of the
brilliant work of Hussein policy